[Musique]
non
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire on dénonce régulièrement
l'ingérence russe
la paire ya l'islam et rypien où
l'influencé chinoise
mais qu'en est il de la france peut-on
parler comme on l'a fait récemment
d'ingérence française au liban après la
visite des manuels maquereau au mois
d'août et en afrique
y at-il à gérance de la france et le
droit d'ingérence humanitaire que nous
avons commencé à théoriser il ya deux
siècles pendant la guerre d'indépendance
grecque contre les turcs
est ce que c'est le faux nez dont
s'affublent pour aller faire la loi chez
les autres comme cela nous est reproché
pour en débattre nous avons invité le
général dominique train quand vous avez
été chef de la mission militaire
française auprès de l'onu vous avez mené
les négociations pour le déploiement le
déploiement d'un contingent français au
liban ou en afrique
vous avez même commandé des bataillons
français au liban et en exclu gosses la
vie alors pour vous où commence
l'ingérence ckoi l'ingérence général la
gérance c'est à partir du moment où un
état impose à un autre état sans que
celui-ci le demandent une action
et c'est donc une imposition si vous
voulez cesser relève un peu du chapitre
7 de la charte des nations unies par
exemple oui mais alors là vous fait la
distinction entre l'état ses dirigeants
et sa population parfois c'est la
population qui pourrait demander et pas
les dirigeants oui ça pourrait être le
cas effectivement et c'est le cas de la
gérance humanitaire en particulier
lorsqu il y à des atteintes graves aux
droits de l'homme c'est ce qui a été
théorisée à l'époque de monsieur
kouchner en particulier et est donc dans
ce cas là les dirigeants pourraient ne
pas le souhaiter alors que la population
le souhaite mais stéphane rials se vous
êtes professeur de philosophie politique
et de relations internationales à
l'université paris ii panthéon assas
vous êtes le président du consiel
scientifique de la revue droit une revue
française de théories de philosophie et
de culture juridique pour vous ça
commence quand la gérance et bien il ya
une définition de l'ingérence qui est
dans le vocabulaire cornu qui est là
la bible des jeunes juristes immixtions
sans titre dans la gestion des affaires
d'autrui
donc à partir du moment où on a un titre
à intervenir il n'y a pas d'ingérence
par exemple s'il y a une autorisation du
conseil de sécurité ou bien si il y à
une invitation une sollicitation à
intervenir alors en 3 secondes
au liban on a parlé d'ingérence je n'ai
pas bien compris pourquoi puisque les
choses se sont presque passés quoi qu'on
ait pensé d'un certain nombre d'aspects
des manières de monsieur lac rond se
sont presque passés comme si les
autorités libanaises avait agréé au
moins la venue de monsieur macro n'y a
donc pas d'ingérence
le président aoun est allé l'accueillir
à l'aéroport
cet entretien s'est entretenu avec lui
donc je pense qu'on n'est pas dans le
cas justement d'une immixion sans titre
dans la gestion des affaires d'autrui on
reparlera de la visite des manuels
maquereau au liban guînes mihaely vous
êtes historien vous êtes le directeur de
la rédaction du magazine causeur le
directeur de la publication de la revue
conflit alors pour vous la gérance ça
commence quand alors on a vu avec mes
deux précédents que la définition le
dictionnaire la définition juridique
pose problème donc je dirais que
l'ingérence c'est l'intervention des
autres cas nous sont contre
l'intervention
on l'appelle en gérance et canon on
souhaite intervenir en soutien de
l'intervention
on trouve la justification juridique la
jst imiter de discours pour les rendre
acceptables
un amor elie vous êtes historienne
professeur honoraire à l'université
libre de bruxelles et vous êtes l'auteur
de principes élémentaires de propagande
de guerre aux éditions quartier libre un
livre qui a fait beaucoup parler qui
continue de faire beaucoup parler
alors pour vous la gérance ça commence
quand eh bien
lorsqu'on s'ingère dans une affaire ça
veut dire qu'on se mêle de cette affaire
sans en avoir le droit ni l'autorisation
est pour moi l'exemple de la yougoslavie
en 99 et clairement un exemple
d'ingérence de l'otan dans les affaires
de la yougoslavie en 99 au souvenir que
l'otan a bombardé belgrade
parce que parce que les serbes à ce
moment là ne voulait pas laisser
l'indépendance du kosovo il ya
d'ailleurs toujours à belgrade les
immeubles détruits à cette occasion
alors revenons pour commencer ce débat
sur la visite d' emmanuel macron au
liban il faut rappeler qu'il a été le
premier dirigeant à se rendre au liban
juste après l'explosion du port de
beyrouth et il est il a tenu 10 10 est
il à mettre la pression sur les les
dirigeants libanais c'est lui qui a
employé la l'expression il a appelé à de
profonds changements et c'est jean luc
mélenchon qui a parlé le premier d'âge
errance il a dit attention ça commence à
ressembler à de la gérance d'autres ont
repris l'expression par la suite
emmanuel macron d'ailleurs à la
ala répondu si la france ne joue pas son
rôle
la gérance sera celle d'autres
puissances sous-entendu lui l'iran bien
entendu alors là en l'occurrence
stéphane rials ça a commencé à répondre
mais est ce qu'il y avait un gérance ou
est ce qu'il y avait risque d'ingérence
est ce que le mot était bien choisi
général trinquant non moi me connaissant
particulièrement le liban je dirais que
il y avait à la fois un mouvement de la
population qui souhaitaient une
intervention extérieure on se souvient
de toutes les manifestations qui avaient
sur la place des martyrs est à la fois
comme ça a été précisé tout à l'heure le
président aoun est venu accueillir le
président de la république
l'ensemble des partis y compris le
hezbollah ne se sont pas opposés à la
présence du président macron les deux
fois d'ailleurs la première fois et la
deuxième fois et donc je pense que
j'avais dire il a joué un rôle
en venant sur place de médiateurs ou
d'accélérateur de mouvements qui était
souhaité à la fois par la population est
un petit peu imposé aux dirigeants
qu'ils n'arrivaient pas à bouger
à morelia dames aurélie alors je ne suis
pas d'accord parce que je pense pas que
c'était simplement une visite d'empathie
c'est très gentil de la présenter comme
ça mais je pense que sa 1re relents de
colonialisme je dirais la france a été
la puissance tutélaire du liban et
rêvent d'avoir encore une place dans ce
jeu politique et je pense que on
accepterait absolument pas l' inverse
c'est à dire que la belgique a été la
puissance coloniale du congo on serait
vraiment très étonné que pour résoudre
notre crise politique qui dure depuis
500 jours on est la visite du président
du de la république démocratique du
congo ou du président burundais qui
viendrait nous expliquer qu'elles sont
en fait nos nos problèmes
et comment les résoudre donc c'est
toujours ainsi en ce sens unique c'est
l'ancienne puissance coloniale qui va
donner des conseils à son ancienne
colonie
vers un train quant à maude réponses oui
non il s'agissait pas d' empathie j'ai
pas employer de tout ce terme là j'ai
dit que la population libanaise avait
accueilli avec beaucoup de chaleur comme
sait le faire savent le faire les
libanais la présence du président de
macron et que l'ensemble des partis
politiques libanais ont accueilli cette
présence aussi parce qu'il y avait une
espèce d'opposition entre la classe
dirigeante et la population qui
n'arrivait pas à déboucher sur un
résultat est que le président macron
d'une certaine façon est venu pour
mettre un accélérateur
donc ça et c'est pas totalement de
l'empathie de la part du du président
macron c'était un phénomène
d'accélération mais qui a été applaudi
et pour reprendre les oppositions que
vous mettez madame je dis simplement que
la population libanaise dans son
ensemble et l'ensemble des partis ont
accueilli avec bienveillance la venue du
président macron voilà pourquoi je pense
qu'il n'ya pas d'ingérence gilmour ali
oui il faut aussi rappeler qu'il y à
quelques milliers de soldats français
qui sont positionnées dans le sud du
liban que la france a joué un rôle dans
le décès de feu de 2006 après la guerre
de l'été entre israël risque mal à s'en
aller plus loin la france joue un rôle
particulier dans ce pays
je sais que certains j'ai même entendu
des amis libanais qu'ils étaient outrés
mais c'était plutôt de la manière dont
macron à s'exprimer publiquement
l'effet que la france essaye
d'intervenir pour faciliter même si l'on
peut dire que ça ça sert aussi les
intérêts de la france je vois pas le le
problème aussi longtemps qu'il y en ait
une convergence entre les intérêts
libanais les intérêts français je trouve
que c'est parfaitement légitime mais je
pense que ce qu'il a fait publiquement a
fortement desservi l'effort diplomatique
et autres économique qu'il est en train
de qu'il est en train de mener qui lui
me semble parfaitement injustifiée mais
gilbert est libre pour reprendre la
définition vous donniez tout à l'heure
vous disiez la gérance c'est toujours
celle des autres là on voit bien qu
emmanuel macron quand on lui dit un
gérant s'il dit non non pas ingérence
mais si on joue pas notre rôle
sous-entendu qui n'est pas de
l'ingérence en revanche d'autres
puissances elles vont faire de la
gérance et il pense évidemment à l'iran
il aurait pensé autrefois les scieries
qui étaient très présentes au liban qui
aujourd'hui on a peut-être moins les
moyens
est-ce que ça répond aussi à ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure au fond la gérance
c'est celle des autres oui tout à fait
ce qu'on appelle la communauté
internationale n'est pas un république
il n'y a pas un puissance tiers comme en
france l'état la justice
y'a pas des monopoles internationale sur
l'utilisation de là la violence donc les
rapports entre les états ne sont pas
comme le rapport entre le citoyen au
sein d'un état en donnerait public
si c'est pas la france va être quelqu'un
d'autre
donc puisque la france joue
jouit d'un avantage c'est davantage des
liens qui sont qui sont anciens
c'est davantage de de la langue
française de la culture française c'est
aussi les avantages tout simplement de
fait qu'il ya énormément de libanais qui
sont aussi français et ont la double
nationalité on aurait pu constater
récemment à quel point on est proches
par les entretiens sur les chaînes télé
et radio les interviews avec des
libanais delarue qui s'exprimait dans
une france est aussi impeccable que le
si c'était des gens à marseille ou à g
pas à nice donc il ya un véritable et
proximité des liens entre les élites pas
uniquement et et la france
ils ont ils étudient souvent en france
ils ont deux membres de leur famille en
france ils ont des amis en france des
liens de économique en france et tout
cela s'est traduit par quelque chose qui
est en statut incertain pouvoir d'
influence qu on aura tort de se priver
stéphane rials puisque ce que je pense
c'est que le bout un gérant ce n'est pas
adapté mais connaît au moins ce qui a
été dit sur les nostalgiques la
puissance mandataire n'est pas excessif
c'est à dire que la france comme
d'ailleurs l'angleterre les deux grandes
puissances régionales mandataire de la
sdn continue à jouer un rôle
considérable peut être surdimensionnés
et s'il s'agit c'est ce que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure du thon de monsieur
macron du choix des termes je pense que
même s'il n'y a pas eu ingérence il ya
peut-être eu disons un petit peu trop
d'autoritarisme dans le ton qui n'était
pas forcément bienvenues et qui peut
faire soupçonner
l'arrière-pensée d'ingérence voilà ce
qu'on peut dire je pense il ya aussi
quelque chose qui est sous-entendu c'est
que quand on donne de l'argent à fonds
perdus un pays
est ce qu'on a le droit d'y mettre des
conditions politiques
on sait bien qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'argent qui a été donnée au liban mais
oublions la question du liban plus
généralement elle ce qu'on a le droit
est-ce que plus tôt est ce que c'est de
la gérance quand on commence à demander
en échange de l'argent qu'on vous donne
au fond on met quelques conditions
politiques à cela morelli alors moi
j'aurais voulu peut-être revenir sur la
définition de monsieur michaeli je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec lui pour dire
que l'ingérence c'est toujours celle des
autres c'est un peu comme l'information
et la propagande
nous faisons de l'information les autres
font de la propagande et donc lorsque
nous un filtre on dans un pays pour lui
porter la bonne parole pour lui apporter
et la démocratie etc
on ne présente là évidemment jamais
comme de l'ingérence c'est simplement de
la bonté d'âme de là une volonté
d'élargir la démocratie etc
et je crois que c'est très important de
voir qu'il ya ce double langage et que
lorsque ma crevette son discours
au liban on en retient que l'aspect
généreux je dirais oui ils apportent de
l'argent et bien sûr en contrepartie il
va demander certaines choses je pense
qu'on devrait aussi mettre un petit peu
l'accent sur les contreparties
économiques
est-ce que l'armement du liban n'est pas
essentiellement de provenance française
même l'armement qui selon amnistie
internationale sert à réprimer les
émeutes les manifestations et donc il ya
là des marchés des marchés qu'il faut
soutenir et la france soutient ces
marchés comme l'italie soutient ces
marchés en libye
ea ou ailleurs réponse générale
trinquant oui juste un point pour
parvenir sur les marchés d'armement du
liban qui croyez moi j'en connais le
sujet sont vraiment quelque chose de
très léger voire anecdotique
en revanche j'ai beaucoup apprécié
l'intervention sur ce qui se fait en
2006 parce que je voudrais rappeler que
le fond c'est que le liban est toujours
en guerre contre israël et que en 2006
israël était intervenu au liban et que
s'il y a une résolution qui a ramené la
paix dans cette zone
c'est en particulier parce que la france
était au conseil de sécurité à la
manoeuvre a rédigé la la résolution mais
non seulement ça mais à assurer la
garantie du sud liban de l'évacuation de
l'armée israélienne par la présence de
forces françaises j'ai eu l'honneur de
commander un bataillon là bas bien avant
mais un bataillon français plus des
italiens plus des espagnols et ce sont
douze mille hommes qui se sont déployés
pour assurer la garantie à la fois elle
ira elle est à la fois au liban et je
pense que les libanais sont redevables à
la france des efforts qu'elle fait en
permanence pour installer la paix dans
ce pays
donc c'est pour ça que les récentes
interventions je pense vu du côté
libanais ne sont pas quelque chose de
très choquant compte tenu du rôle que la
france tient bien sûr il ya un siècle
mais aussi actuellement deal mais à eli
est ce qu'on a le droit de mettre des
conditions où est ce que c'est de
l'ingérence quand on donne de l'argent à
un état ce sont des relations de pouvoir
bien évidemment quand on donne de
l'argent c'est pas l'argent de quelqu'un
c'est l'argent public 10 ans
donc les les citoyens français ont le
droit de savoir pourquoi on a donné cet
argent là aux libanais pourquoi cette
somme là à quoi ça sert en quoi ça ça
renforce la sécurité de la france en
quoi ça contribue à la prospérité de la
france
est-ce que ça va créer des des deux
emplois est-ce que ça va apporter
quelque chose d positives à la france
c'est comme ça qu'il faut il faut voir
les choses
après évidemment la question est quels
sont ces conditions si pour prendre un
exemple très concret liban est dans
l'impasse
les systèmes bancaire s'est écroulé et
les discussions avec les fonds monétaire
international sont coincés parce qu'une
partie de la classe politique libanaise
qui tient la clé de la légalité mais qui
n'est plus d'un qui n'est plus légitime
c'est ça la définition même d'une crise
politique bloque les négociations avec
les familles les spécialistes y compris
le haut fonctionnaire libanais disent
que la position de ceux qui bloquent
l'accord avec les faits me sont pas
raisonnables que des gens sont en train
de garder leur pré carré que votre mode
x et la corruption
donc si la france exige à la classe
politique libanaise dé trouver un accord
qui représente qui exprime l'intérêt
général pour pouvoir sauver le système
bancaire pour pouvoir sauver l'économie
je vois pas le problème et c'est juste
un exemple stéphane rials oui enfin si
on si on ne veut pas accepter l'argent
on peut le refuser
donc je ne dirais pas d'ingérence là
dedans même dans ces conditions
par contre à l'arrière-plan des propos
et de la présence du président macron il
y avait évidemment une vue politique une
vue géopolitique orientale une vue
politique aussi qu'on peut considérer
comme disons néolibérale et en ce sens
il n'ya pas ingérence mais il y à bien
une action proprement politique tendant
à exercer une certaine pression à la
fois internationale et aussi sur le plan
du contenu des réformes économiques
donc c'est pas d'ingérence mais c'est
pas non plus quelque chose de neutre
c'est entre les deux justement l époque
où la grèce avait à faire à ce qu'on
appelait la troïka on se souvient
beaucoup de gens ont employé le mot
ingérence en disant ben voilà la troïka
quand elle est susceptible de prêter de
l'argent à la grèce elle y met des
conditions des conditions économiques
mais qui deviennent rapidement des
conditions politiques et c'est de
l'ingérence
c'est la même question pour moi à partir
du moment où tu donnes de l'argent où on
en prête
est ce qu'on a le droit de mettre des
conditions sans qu'on vous dise vous
faites de la gérant stéphane rials
disons que l'ingérence la vraie on la
connaît ça a été par exemple la libye
alors là il y a eu une ingérence qu'on
ne peut placer sous aucune autre
catégorie que l'ingérence
dès lors qu'on n'atteint pas un certain
type de configuration
je crois qu'il vaut mieux ne pas
utiliser au fond polémique mans le mot
ingérence sachant qu'il ya déjà beaucoup
de matière à polémiquer contre les
propos du président macron et contre
peut-être une partie de ces démarches
ingérence n'ajoute rien voilà mon
sentiment
pour ce qui est de rendre compte ce
qu'il s'est passé au liban
quelqu'un d'autre veut ajouter quelque
chose
anne morelli moi mon obsession si vous
voulez c'est le l'utilisation des termes
c'est à dire que si c'est un de nos amis
on ne va jamais employer ce mot
d'ingérence on va toujours leur refuser
on va lui prêter des motivations purent
alors que si c'est quelqu'un d'un autre
quand on va tout de suite allé voir ses
préoccupations géostratégiques et
économiques
or moi je pense que dans toutes les
actions de politique internationale il
ya ces deux dimensions
il ya la géostratégie et il
l'économie et la géostratégie est
aujourd'hui extrêmement présent dans le
moyen-orient où chacun essaie d'avancer
ses pions et la france parmi d'autres il
me ravit oui je suis d'accord mais je
pense que juste que pour moi ça me
semble parfaitement légitime voire
nécessaire donc ça ne me dérange pas du
tout et pour tout vous dire si grâce au
rôle que la france est en train de jouer
au liban si jamais ça aboutit dans
quelque chose de positif
les sociétés françaises augmentent leurs
ventes sur ses marchés tant mieux je
pense pas que c'est un mauvaise c'est un
mauvais nouvel usage disons de la
puissance française dominique trinquant
oui j'avoue ne pas bien comprendre ce
que c'est que la pureté en géopolitique
évidemment que dans un des actions comme
ça il ya des arrière pensées
géopolitique
ces actions qui sont entreprises pour le
liban
naturellement pour le bien du liban
évidemment mais aussi pour la position
de la france dans la région et je vois
rien de contradictoire à ça ça fait rire
borelli vous pouvez nous dire pourquoi
oui pour le bien qu'on intervient
toujours pour le bien des autres
on est allés libérer les pauvres femmes
afghanes qui voulaient porter le bikini
au lieu de la burqa on est allés libérer
les kosovars en va toujours libérer des
gens les aider c'est toujours très beau
mais je pense que nos actions ne sont
pas poussés par cette pureté 8 5 ans
donc comme je le dis je ne vois pas où
est la pureté
je sais que c'est vous qui les employés
madame pas moi je dis simplement que
c'est pas parce qu'on va aider le liban
qu'on n'a pas des arrière-pensées
politiques pour la france géopolitique
plutôt pour le rôle de la france à la
fois sur cette zone et dans le monde
je le rappelais lorsqu'en 2006 il a
fallu négocier
1 un accord pour installer la paix au
liban c'est la france qui a tenu la
plume c'est la france qui a rapproché
les opposer et c'est la france qui a
déployé ses soldats alors elle l'a fait
et je le pense pour le bien du liban
puisque ça arrêtez la guerre de 2006
mais elle a fait aussi bien sûr pour le
rôle important que la france joue comme
membre permanent du conseil de sécurité
il ya je le trouve que le terme pureté
est totalement étranger à ce type de à
ce type de relation que nous entretenons
je rappelle que les états ont des
intérêts et l'intérêt de la france et
bien sûr de jouer un rôle important à la
place qui est la sienne
ce qui est curieux c'est que on dit
jamais on va aller faire la guerre
là-bas pour étendre notre zone d'intérêt
un jeu de stratégie ou pour défendre nos
équipes nos intérêts économiques
ça on ne le dit jamais mais on présente
toujours sassou des motivations
humanitaires sous des motivations nobles
et la réalité des objectifs n'est jamais
passé dans l'opinion publique on fait
une pause on repense veba juste apprend
va quitter le liban et on va
s'intéresser à l'afrique
[Musique]
c'est déjà une bonne idée d'investir
dans autre chose que des produits
financiers il faut savoir que quand on
achète une pierre précieuse toujours
toujours toujours avoir le certificat
qui est parfait et qui est reconnue au
niveau du commentaire que vous avez
beaucoup de gens qui sont sortis de
leurs investissements je dirais
classiques et sont allés se réfugier sur
du tangible
il ya plusieurs risques il faut il faut
il faut les prendre en compte si on fait
si on n'est pas très bien ces lieux là
il faut savoir que quand vous achetez
une pierre c'est pas pour les dix jours
qui suivent
et c'est un investissement de long terme
le marché des pierres précieuses bon
évidemment s'arrêter un petit peu plus
ou moins de travailler pendant deux mois
mais les grands firme minière ou pour le
diamant retiennent la marchandise en
amont pour maintenir les prix des prix
assez élevé
pensez vous que malgré les apparences la
france joue un rôle dans l'élection à
venir en côte d'ivoire france 3 c'est un
cycle de polichinelle je ne pourrais pas
qu'il appartient à la france dé l'eau
des problèmes entre ivoiriens le
président ouattara et son régime sont en
train d'imprimer leurs prix
il faut demander au régime ivoiris
déférents sorte d n'est pas crisper
davantage les positions l'attention à
toulouse vous demandé un report des
scrutins prévus le 31 octobre
organiser les élections en côte d'ivoire
là les ciconstances paris c'est le
conduit la côte d'ivoire dans un menu
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur la gérance avec
le général dominique trinquant qui a été
chef de la mission militaire française
auprès l'onu avec stéphane rials ce qui
est professeur de philosophie politique
et de relations internationales à
l'université paris ii avec guy lemire a
émis le directeur du magazine causeur et
le directeur de la publication de la
revue conflit et anne morelli qui est
historienne et quelle hauteur de
principes élémentaires de propagande de
guerre aux éditions quartier libre alors
revenons-en à l'afrique et commençons
tout de suite par une carte cette carte
elle est parue dans manière de voir qui
est le la revue bimestrielle du monde
diplomatique et cette carte c'est la
carte d intervention militaire française
en afrique
alors quand on la voit comme ça c'est
assez impressionnant et on se dit
bastien c'était les chinois ou les
russes ou même les américains on se
dirait il ya là il ya quand même
ingérence mais comme c'est les français
on va pas utiliser le mot ingérence
alors qu'est ce que c'est pour vous
gerald traquant cette carte vous la
connaissez quand on voit toutes ces
interventions militaires françaises
il faut les voir comment pour vous bien
c'est toujours pareil
je rappelle que selon l'article 51 de la
charte des nations unies qui s'appelle
qui autorise les états à se défendre
ils ont aussi le droit d'appeler à leur
secours un autre pays
alors si on prend les deux dernières
interventions que vous connaissez bien
sûr qui sont celles du miley et la
centrafrique et bien au mali la france
est intervenue à la demande du
gouvernement malien donc s de
l'ingérence puisque c'est à la demande
alors évidemment les années s'écoulent
en ont dit que la population de bamako
et n'est pas content d'avoir les troupes
françaises je suis pas persuadé qu à
kidal ont disent la même chose ni à à
gao
donc il faudrait analyser chacune de ces
de ses interventions je ne dis pas qu'il
ya pas eu d'ingérence des moments il
faudrait refaire l'historique de tout
cela je n'ai pris que les deux dernières
intervention pour illustrer mon propos
stéphane rials ce quand vous voyez cette
carte vous voyez quoi je reviendrai
volontiers sur cette notion d'
intervention sur invitation sur
sollicitation est uniquement de
l'autorité légale
alors effectivement ce que disait le
général trinquant est tout à fait juste
si on est invité à aller dans un pays il
n'y a pas de motif majeur de ne pas y
aller
par contre je veux dire de motif légal
de ne pas y aller
par contre ce qu'on observe au mali
c'est ce que j'appellerais la ruse
maligne n'ont pas de l'ingérence mais de
l'intervention sur sollicitation ou sur
invitation
c'est que au début on arrive et on est
accueilli au fond de la meilleure
manière qui soit et puis dans la durée
on devient pour beaucoup de gens le
général trinquant pensé qu'il ne fallait
pas surestimer ce nombre mais pau pour
beaucoup de gens une puissance occupante
et une puissance du coup qui perd sa
légitimité
d'autant qu'à mesure l'autorité légale
qui a appelé au au début n'est pas
forcément la même si bien que si on voit
la situation simplement du mali on y est
allés dans un motif dans une perspective
très particulière très précis serait
très très ajustée qui était d'éliminer
en quelque sorte la radicalité islamique
et on voit aujourd'hui que l'imam dicko
formé en arabie séoudite qui est par
ailleurs certes un ami de la france que
l'imam dicko est en train de devenir il
dit qu'il va retourner à ses affaires
ordinaires en train de devenir un
personnage tout à fait central à nouveau
et on peut assez bien imaginer que à
court terme ou à moyen terme
après peut-être des élections très
soigneusement encadré qui suivrait le
moment militaires que nous connaissons
on peut tout à fait imaginer qu'on se
retrouve à la case départ en quelque
sorte
alors c'est moins ici la question de
l'illégalité de notre présence puisque
je ne crois pas qu'il y ait illégalité
au sens du droit international que de la
rationalité de long terme de ce genre
d'actions qui se pose me semble-t-il
guilhemery au fond pourquoi la france
intervient si souvent dans ces pays et
marc mot dans d'autres parce que ces
pays là ne fonctionne pas si la france
est intervenue en janvier 2013 au mali
c'est parce que l'état malien était en
faillite et que l'armée malienne s'est
évaporé des vins quelques colonnes de
4,4 franchement appelé son armée s'est
même en abus de langage face à cela une
armée qui a été formé pendant des années
a dit a disparu donc il ya un grave
problème et comme comme l'avait dit mon
prédécesseur là on a passé de cerval qui
est tout sauvetage de bamako et
les leurs et pousser les colons qui sont
venus du nord à barkan et barkan c'est
pas une intervention militaire barkan
c'est une opération qui s'inscrit dans
la durée
la france ne peut pas arrêter
l'opération barkan parce que il ya
personne pour prendre la relève
même les g5 donc les les autres pays de
la mauritanie au niger qui doivent avec
l'armée malienne qui n'existent pas
toujours à mon nom un autre constitué
s'efforçant mais ses forces armées
cette force armée capable de de tenir et
de soutenir en souveraineté
qik digne de ce nom on n'est pas prêt on
n'est pas prêt on n'est pas prêt à les
voir et si on le fait pas si on ne le
fait pas on aura des attentats au
bataclan à charlie hebdo on aura des
norad et des migrants encore plus en
grèce en italie en espagne
c'est très concret et ce qu'on voit pas
faire là-bas à quelques milliers de
kilomètres d'ici
on va le faire à quelques centaines de
mètres de studio où en sont nous sommes
aujourd'hui c'est aussi simple que ça
anne morelli
oui alors la question du mali est
intéressant parce que il ya cet appel à
une puissance qui doit venir rétablir
l'ordre alors c'est un vieux système via
une stratégie de propagande on dit pas
nous allons intervenir mais nous sommes
appelés et un gouvernement qui joue un
fantoche peut toujours rappeler une
puissance étrangère à venir intervenir
alors ça pose la question est ce qu'on
doit toujours répondre aussi si demain
les ukrainiens demande d'intervenir
contre la russie où les estoniens est ce
que nous allons répondre à leur demande
et d'autre part il ya toujours cette
question de vocabulaire est ce que les
français au mali sont des occupants ou
des libérateurs
alors je répondrai par une petite
question présente qu'on me posait quand
j'étais enfant ma famille pour moitié
napolitaine à naples il y avait une
présence américaine militaire très
visible et on nous demandait quelle est
la différence entre un pays libre et un
pays occupé et la réponse c'est que le
pays libre il est occupé par les troupes
américaines
ça me fait pas rire tout le monde
général trinquant souris mais ça va je
trouve
pardonnez moi mais je trouve ça trouve
ça toujours un petit peu décalé
évidemment qu'on n'est pas obligé de
répondre
à l'appel d'un pays qui est dans la
difficulté mais là je reviens toujours
aux intérêts des états dont je parlais
tout à l'heure si nous répondons sait
que c'est dans notre intérêt aussi
et ceci a très bien été démontrée tout à
l'heure la menace jihadiste dans cette
zone du sahel
c'est notre frontière sud et que si nous
n'intervenons pas là nous risquons
d'intervenir chez nous donc on avait
intérêt à intervenir
et en plus comme cela a été également
exposés c'est tout à fait légal puisque
c'est un pays qui nous l'a demandé alors
madame par le gouvernement fantoche
moi je veux bien bon cd gouvernement
légalement élu 1 donc on peut mettre en
cause la légalité de l'élection de ces
pays et en revanche l'évolution
aujourd'hui moi je la comprends
parfaitement de la part d'un certain
nombre de maliens
si vous voulez intervenir en 2013 est
toujours présent en 2020
que se passe-t-il il y adeux
l'impatience à la fois sur la réforme de
l'état est à la fois sur le combat
contre les djihadistes donc je la
comprends cette impatience et c'est à
nous de prouver que le combat que nous
menons en particulier pas à bamako je
rappelle n'y a pas de troupes françaises
à bamako et les manifestations ont lieu
à bamako
donc le combat que nous menons dans le
nord en particulier dans la zone des
trois frontières et efficace pour
réduire la menace djihadiste
mais ensuite bien sûr c'est aux états de
prendre la responsabilité d'établir la
paix nous nous faisons en sorte que les
armes se taisent et ensuite il faut que
les états eux installe d'état de droit
dans leur région c'est vrai que
notamment en afrique mais pas seulement
en afrique
le fait qu'un cas d'états ou qu'un
gouvernement soit démocratiquement élu
ou pas est-ce que ça change
on se souvient que les américains
répondaient à l'appel de du gouvernement
suit vietnamien qui est une dictature à
l'époque exactement comme les
soviétiques
répondant à l'appel du gouvernement
afghan
1979 qui n'est évidemment pas
démocratique et nous il nous arrive de
répondre à l'appel de dictateurs
africains qui n'ont jamais été lu par
personne et et que l'on soutient parfois
contre une rébellion qu'on peut paraître
qui peut paraître par ailleurs
totalement justifiée comment est-ce
qu'on s'y prendre aussi qu'elle a alors
on peut se dire bonjour n'obéit à notre
intérêt mais ça ne suffit pas ça ne peut
pas nous suffit guynemer ali bon il faut
il faut espérer que ceux qui prennent la
décision prend en compte tous les
aspects qu'est ce que ça nous qu'est ce
que ça nous apporte
et surtout quelle est l'alternative
souvent des choses qui semblent très
moche même quand on ne décide pas
uniquement aux rétrospectivement on est
con c'est sens obligé de le faire parce
que l'alternative est encore pire
sauf que ce truc moche et pas bien c'est
la chose qu'on voit qu'on peut critiquer
c'est la réalité et c'est qu'on a
empêché personne ne peut le voir
donc je pense que souvent souvent c'est
le cas et on a rare on arrive rarement à
a vraiment posé la question si on le
faisait pas quelle serait la situation
aujourd'hui c'est à ça qu'il faut qu'il
faut réfléchir c'est la question c'était
effectivement posée après l'invasion de
l'irak par les américains ils ont dit
mais ça aurait été pire si on n'y était
pas allé on peut se poser la question
effectivement
et puis la france a toujours libye en
libye on dit encore ben si on n'y était
pas allé il y aurait eu des massacres
non mais je ne dis pas que là c'est
toujours le monde le moindre mal
peut-être parfois c'est pire
on ne sait pas dans les cas de la libye
moi je pensais que c'était une mauvaise
idée d'intervenir mais
je prends pas à la légère l'argument
conquois cette 32e brigade division de
l'armée libyenne allait faire un
massacre à benghazi avec deux de
milliers ou des dizaines de milliers de
deux morts et cela a été empêché par
l'action aérienne entre autres de la
france on peut aussi se poser la
question est ce que la suite était
absolument inéluctable est-ce qui après
avoir sauvé benghazi
on aurait pu faire autrement peut-être
c'est clair qu'aujourd'hui on vit avec
les conséquences de ce qui s'est passé
en 2012 et pas avec les conséquences de
ce qui aurait pu se passer si on n'a
rien de faire on ne rien fait et alors
je répète et j'assume j'étais contre
mais je ne néglige pas et je tiens je ne
prends pas à la légère les arguments
s'en sert de ceux qui voulaient empêcher
un massacre
l époque on y va pour empêcher un
massacre mais par ailleurs on renverse
le dictateur tout le monde à ce moment
là n'est pas d'accord est ce que là il
ya est-ce que la gérance admettons pour
la gérance humanitaire qui consiste à
empêcher le massacre mais la gérance qui
consiste à renverser le dictateur parce
que personne ne nous avait demandé
est ce que c'est mais pas est ce qu'on
n'a pas franchi un pas la générale
trinquant oui c'est d'ailleurs ce que
nous reproche en particulier la russie
et la chine
puisque vous savez que la résolution
sous chapitre 7 qui avait été adoptée à
l'époque à la demande de la france
demandé d'intervenir mais que
l'abstention de la russie et de la chine
a été obtenue par ce que il était
compris qui aurait certaines limites et
ses limites ont été franchies ceux qui
depuis amène à une grosse difficulté
dans l'adoption des résolutions aux
côtés de conseil de sécurité donc je
suis d'accord avec vous on a
probablement été au delà de ce qui était
autorisé
beaucoup de pays africains nous le
reproche à le président issoufou en
particulier l'a dit très clairement il a
dit moi on m'a jamais demandé mon avis
alors que ma frontière nord et est
proche et sur la frontière libyenne
donc beaucoup d'africains reproche le
fait qu'on ait renversé un dictateur
sanguinaire certes mais qui apportait
malgré tout une certaine stabilité dans
cette zone donc je pense que ça peut ça
peut se discuter effectivement et cette
résolution est peut-être allé trop loin
maintenant comme cela vient d'être dit
aujourd'hui il est plus facile de
regarder les choses comme ça moi j'ai
souvenir pour est allé à tripoli après
le départ de du président kadhafi
d'avoir vu un pays qui avait fait des
élections qui avaient fait une nouvelle
constitution et dont on pouvait penser
qu'il allait vers le chemin de la paix
il n'a pas été accompagnée du tout dans
cette période-là tout le monde l'a
laissé tomber et ensuite on est revenu
aux vieux démons qui sont de prendre les
armes pour essayer d'imposer sa loi
c'est fade rial oui ce qu'a dit le
général trinquant et très juste le
conseil de sécurité se trouve en quelque
sorte
bloqué par la façon dont l' affaire
libyenne a tourné monsieur juppé était
allé pour remporter si j'ose dire le
morceau et il l'avait emporté
en réalité il y avait des arrière
pensées qui était belle et trop loin
simplement un certain nombre de
personnes ne veulent plus jouer avec
nous en quelque sorte au conseil de
sécurité c'est le cas effectivement de
la russie en particulier de la chine
alors l'autre aspect peut-être c'est que
lorsque on intervient à des motifs ont
supposément où effectivement humanitaire
on a aussi l'intention de faire du
changement global de régimes économiques
politiques et cetera après do
l'élimination de mouammar kadhafi a
supposé qu'il lui ait eu que ces aspects
mais laissons de côté un certain nombre
d'autres d'autres allégations des on
nous lorsque on veut en quelque sorte
remodelée sur notre modèle supposé un
certain nombre de pays on les plonge
dans de très grandes difficultés muamar
kadhafi était un homme très brillant
homme politique intérieure et ça je
crois qu'on n'en parle pas souvent
qu'ils savaient très bien faire
fonctionner ce monde très complexe
qu'est le monde libyen qui ne renvoient
pas seulement à l'opposition cyrénaïque
tripolitaine si vous voulez mais à une
fragmentation qui est la fragmentation
des sociétés traditionnelles et le
colonel kadhafi savait très bien trouver
les transactions que ces systèmes appel
si bien que le beau système qui a si
brièvement marché que l'on a mis en
place après s'est trouvé en quelque
sorte miné par le fait qu'il n'était pas
forcément adaptées à la structure
sociale
on fait comme si on pouvait plaques et
des systèmes économiques des systèmes
politiques sur des sociétés quelle
qu'elle soit et ses sociétés très
diverse réagissent très différemment à
ce type de système qui n'opèrent pas
tous de là toujours de la même manière
selon les sociétés auxquelles on
sa clique mais justement quand on veut
changer un régime politique
est-ce que cela ça n'est pas de
l'ingérence et de la même manière qu'on
a voulu changer le système politique
libyen d'après vous est ce que quand on
veut changer aujourd'hui le système
politique libanais qui lui aussi repose
sur quelque chose de très complexe au
liban et à dia c'est une société
multiculturelle avec des religions très
différentes et tout le système politique
est basée là-dessus
si on arrivait qu'on dit vous mettra une
fois arrêté tout ça et faire une
démocratie comme la nôtre parce que y'a
que ça de bon est-ce qu'on ne joue pas
avec le feu à morelia
alors moi je voulais revenir sur la
libye un instant parce que c'est
vraiment le type même du lieu où on a
développé une propagande sur les
massacres de l'adversaire mais même les
massacres futur supposé ça c'est quand
même un pas en avant intéressant parce
que d'habitude on dénonce les massacres
effectifs mais là c'était les massacres
supposée à venir et puis on avait trouvé
en la personne de kadhafi le monstre par
excellence or dans toute propagande de
guerre
il faut ce monstre il faut concentrer
l'animosité de l'opinion publique sur
une personne et là on avait trouvé le
monstre par excellence alors que comme
viennent de l'expliquer plusieurs des
intervenants avant moi c'était un
personnage certes complexe mais qui
avait maintenu la libye dans un état de
relative prospérité calme qui me qu'elle
ne connaît plus depuis notre
intervention
alors on a toujours besoin de ces mêmes
principes pour déclencher une
intervention qu'on va cacher sous des
des attraits humanitaire et on s'attaque
toujours un monstre et à quelqu'un qui
fait des choses d'un point de vue
humanitaire qui sont insupportables
alors je dirais que c'est maintenant
peut-être vers poutine que on s'adresse
c'est le monstre par excellence la
sphère navalni émises en épingle dans
nos pays on parle de la vanille et mise
en épingle dans nos pays on parle de lui
accorder l'asile politique mais personne
ne parle de l'asile politique pour snob
donne-nous assange
donc ce ne sont pas des mobiles je vais
revenir sur ce terme qui m'a été
contesté tout à l'heure ce ne sont pas
des mobiles pure mais bien sûr ce sont
des mobiles qui interviennent parce que
on a besoin de trouver une cause pour
attaquer la nulle autre pays et je suis
étonné qu'on ne parle plus jamais de
guerre on parle d'opération on parle
d'intervention
d'ailleurs nous n'avons même plus de
ministère de la guerre autrefois la
première guerre mondiale il n'y avait un
ministère de la guerre
aujourd'hui ça s'appelle le ministère de
la défense donc si tous les états se
défendre ben il ne devrait pas y avoir
de guerre parce que il ya aucun pays qui
est un ministère de l' attaque
or les ingérences ce sont des formes
d'attac d'imrali ma question sur le
liban est ce qu'on peut et est-ce qu'on
puisse vouloir changer la forme
politique d'un pays
est-ce que ça n'est pas toujours risqué
qu'on entend plus guil ou plutôt il ne
m'entend plus
oui ah oui alors nos aînés ses esprits
et l'isi oui je voulais juste dire à
madame aurélie que peut-être parfois la
meilleure défense est l'attaqué donc
dans le cadre de la mission de défense
on peut aussi attaquer je je je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de ya pas de règles
ce qui a marché au japon en 45 n'a
visiblement pas marcher en irak en 2003
ni en libye en 2012 ni en aviron store
d'ailleurs ce qui nous amène mieux que
nous ce que 12 mn oui mais ce qui nous
amène à et ça marche est aussi en
allemagne
ce qui nous amène à au liban les choses
ne sont pas figées
je pense que les liban est souvent
trajectoire qui va aboutir par une état
nation où toutes les allégeances et les
appartenances qui ne sont pas à une
structure nationale et un intérêt
général devient de moins en moins fort
et finalement on pourrait avoir une
société disons de type occidental
il peut accueillir en démocratie
libérale on n'a pas besoin d'avoir 5
police pour avoir pour chaque tribu une
police pour chaque confession ou service
d'ordre etc etc et où l'intérêt général
tout le monde s'en fout donc peut-être
lé liban était très très loin de cela
en 1960 est peut-être aujourd'hui elle
est très proche et donc peut-être une
politique d'ingérence et des changements
de régime en 1981 est vouée à l'échec et
en 2029
c'est exactement le petit effort qu'il
faut pour les aider à passer à autre
chose
donc je pense pas que changer de régime
ces exclus ça ne pose jamais marché
mais notre expérience c'est que
probablement dans le monde arable ça
arrive trop tôt malheureusement
peut-être en afrique aussi c'est trop
tôt et donc il faut il faut arrêter de
l'essayer mais je pense que au liban
peut être la société murs pour passer à
autre chose on voit que des l'intérieur
il ya un véritable volonté
même si c'est vrai qu'on voit
essentiellement ce qui se passe à bayrou
tu es mons qui se passe à tripoli aux
rats bintje belle au moral est haut dans
le bac à mais j'imagine que c'est assez
représentative
il ya quand même des forces ils sont des
forces nationales et non plus les forces
de l' état d'avant qui est en sorte de
confédération des confessions dernier
mot général trinquant oui l'histoire du
liban est très particulière
il y a un siècle le grand liban a été
créé à l'époque comme une enclave dans
lesquelles les communautés religieuses
pouvait vivre ensemble que ce soit les
chrétiens sunnites ou chiites les
principales mais il ya beaucoup de
l'église chrétienne d'ailleurs là-bas au
passage depuis un siècle les choses ont
évolué et on a bien vu toutes les
manifestations des jeunes libanais sur
la place des martyrs à étaient pour dire
arrêtez ce système confessionnel qui en
fait relève du moyen-âge en ayant mis
des clans qu'on n'arrive pas à sortir de
leurs de leurs 2 du système et et nous
pouvons aller vers une démocratie
beaucoup très différentes
alors je ne suis pas allé au liban
depuis 2006 il ya probablement une
évolution comme ça vient d'être fait
peut-être le liban et ils mûr pour un
système différent de celui qui lie à un
siècle simplement n'oublions pas que
toutes les communautés doivent y trouver
la place
et moi je pense par exemple à la
communauté chrétienne
il faut impérativement que les libanais
qui sont en exil dont une partie grande
partie 2 de chrétiens puissent avoir le
droit de vote sur l'avenir de ce pays
dernier mot stéphane rials il reste très
peu de temps oui je serai très bref je
crois qu'il faut se hâter lentement dans
ces affaires de déconfessionnalisation
parce que nous voyons nous les religions
comme quelque chose qui est au dessus en
quelque sorte et qui est l'objet d'un
choix
mais là ce sont des structurations
intime de la société je ne crois pas
qu'on puisse balayer rapidement ce genre
d' intégration totale
d'apparence confessionnelle mais qui
probablement touche à l'ensemble des
strates de la société
je vous remercie tous les quatre d'avoir
participé à ce débat on a déjà dépassé
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
oh